when I started watching your stuff it
was like one of those things where I'm
like oh yeah why has no one done this
before in in in this kind of way and so
when I see it it's like of course it's
the best ideas they're like right on the
tip of the tongue it's like of course a
photographer that takes beautiful shots
should interview their
subjects it just it's like I've seen a
million a million email messages people
saying this is my idea I wanted to do
this I'm like yeah I know you had to do
it right right and it's hard to do yeah
I can't I dude I can't imagine how how
hard it is but yeah there are some days
that just like you just I know dude
that's why I I don't have any guests on
my podcast I just want to I don't want
to do I want to deal with people you
know it's funny to say as a comic I
guess
but when did you realize you want to be
a comic was he
young um you grew up in new New Jersey I
grew up in New Jersey and and I I
don't I don't know if there was ever a
light bulb moment I I I just I can't
remember a time where I thought I would
do anything else I I just like it's like
remembering when I learned how to walk I
just I I I I my whole family is so
funny and uh it was just always our
language and so
uh we just my dad tells a story
that when I was watching I was on I was
my dad was watching a movie a Jerry
Lewis movie and uh on uh on
TV and I was playing with my toys and I
and Jerry Lewis was done doing something
silly and I he my dad was struck by the
way I stopped playing with my toys and
just was watching like the Jerry Lewis
movie and my dad said uh and and I said
dad is this what is this guy doing and
and and my dad says well that's what he
does that's says he's he's an actor he's
a comedic actor and I said uh like this
is his job and my dad said yeah and I
said and he makes money doing that and
my dad said yeah as a matter of fact he
makes a lot of money doing that and my
dad said that I took a beat and I
said huh and then I went back to my toys
and started playing and he he always
credits that that was the moment that I
realized that I wanted to be funny as a
career which I don't know if it's true
or not but no that makes sense yeah it's
a funny story that's how it happens yeah
you the people that around you oh I
could do that yeah yeah I always loved
making I always loved loved it I I I my
my my family is so funny my my mom is so
funny and my dad is so funny my
brother's so funny all in different ways
and my extended family
and it's funny that to me that I became
the commedian uh I'm definitely the one
that obsesses about it humor and and
being funny but um
they're all so funny that I almost feel
like they should all do it you know yeah
but you learn from being around these
kind of people oh yeah timing just
delivery yeah attitude all those super
important deal there was nothing I liked
more there was nothing I liked more as a
kid than just like making people laugh
and laughing yeah it just and I learned
from my uncles and aunts
and I don't know it was like a language
you know it was like a language it was a
wavelength that we would just we showed
love with each other in that way you
know like we would make fun of each
other but if if we would make fun of
each other it would be it's almost like
if I make fun of you or if or if my
family were to make fun of you that
shows acceptance you know it's like oh I
like you like we're not going to make
fun of we wouldn't make fun of somebody
we didn't like because we don't know we
don't want to deal with that person you
know it's a love it's a way of
communicating love and occasionally
somebody would get their feelings hurt
and then that's where you know know
where the line is and you still push it
anyway but yeah who are you closer to
Mom or
Dad it's a that's a good question I I
think we're very close as a family um
we're really close all of us all of us
um maybe being a a man might it might
skew to to my dad just because of that
um you know my dad was was
uh work my dad was working a lot when I
was a kid but um so I was home with my
mom a lot but I think that once I became
kind of older I really started
like I think the the male angle probably
maybe a little bit closer to my dad mhm
yeah it's it's odd man life is just the
way it keeps going and going and it
like there's just almost like different
versions of
like of these lives it's like when I was
a kid it was a whole different thing I
thought you know I thought my dad was
invincible he could do no wrong and and
I know that's what people say and then
when you become a teenager and then you
don't want to listen to him you're like
f [__] does he know I know everything I
mean
then you grow up and you
realize how much you don't know and then
how much
you realize [__] my dad didn't know this
[__] either you know like I thought he
knew it he was even older than I I know
less and less as I get older my dad's
that old he must know nothing you know
and so um [__] he's 76 now and it's just
like I'm 43
and [__] it's weird though cuz people
get older and older and they look like
they know less you know like like my dad
now does that thing where he's just like
you say his name and he's like what and
you're like what is what is that [__]
what is that what is that that you know
it's like it used to just be like hey yo
and now it's just it's like a whole
reset where it's like oh it's time to
talk now it's like oh [__] you slow down
yeah you slow down so uh it almost looks
like you know less unless which is I
guess interesting [__] I knew so much
when I
was what were what were your teenage
years like um
my teenage years
were you
know I moved to LA or I moved to the
outskirts of Los Angeles cuz my family
was my dad was in the business not not
the standup business but you know uh
Hollywood and
um I I I moved to LA in like the seventh
grade I think it was and that was
like C that was like a a
really I was 12 you know and it was a
really I didn't realize something until
recently and I mean this like in the
last three years um like I I was always
so
um terrified of of of everything I mean
I I couldn't sleep through the night
until I was
maybe 12 I moved to LA and
um I remember I would do I I remember I
uh 90210 the first version not the one
that was a few years ago but the first
version with like um Luke Perry and
Jason prisley and all that Shannon Dy um
I was like that's what la like I'm going
to do my hair like Luke Perry and I went
out to LA and I had my hair and was like
Luke Perry and I was just [__] the
laughing stock I was like look at this
guy's [__] hair I remember the first
thing I was like this hair I was like I
got the hair down and then I got to LA
and people were like this guy's [__]
hair what a joke and I was like oh this
is what you I thought this is what it
was like and
um and I I I became like
this new kid but I remember I was making
I was being made fun of and I was like
man they're laughing at me if I could
just own that and I could just make
them think that they're laughing at me
and I'm part of
it what could that what could that how
could that change
my I guess status you know and I did I I
just I
remember I would be almost bullied but I
would be um I would befriend them you
know because I would make make them
laugh and um but that that's the key
sometimes especially when you're young
to not being a victim yeah it's the key
once once they realize get picking on
you can uh can get to you uh your yeah I
just remember I remember they were cuz I
I you know if you turn it into turn it
into a joke then it becomes like yeah I
was
very and I still am just in my head like
I live in my head I I I just live in my
head and I always have when
I I said I couldn't sleep when I was a
kid uh my parents like took me to these
doctors and the doctors would like show
me a bunch of pictures what do you see
when you see this and I was just like I
don't
[__] a face and they're like okay you
know and they write it down and you're
like is that right I don't know I'm
[__] eight I don't know if I'm
supposed to say a face or a
butterfly and like
uh and then they're just like yeah he's
basically they're just like yeah I don't
know what they say to them but like yeah
your son's just different you know and
you're like okay everyone's [__]
different so it's like what do they mean
man I remember there was there was one
time where I was in science
class and the two people that were
making F that people were that that that
the bully was picking on was me and
another kid and um I remember
feeling really bad for the other kid
because in my head I was like I
know I know I know I can turn this into
me making the bully laugh and I don't
know if that kid can do that and I did
did
and look we were 15 back then and then
you become accepted yeah I did I became
accepted to that guy and I remember the
rest of the year he still kind of
bullied that kid and it wasn't awful but
um I remember I remember thinking like I
wish I wish that I wish that didn't
happen I wish but I was the truth is I
was still scared of the the bully so I
was just kind of but that you know that
comedic Talent is is a advanced social
skill that not everyone has yeah and
people that are victims get swallowed up
and you know what's funny is uh I'm
friends with that bully today I I I I
still know him he's one of my best
friends um and he's a great guy and you
know I think you go through [__] as a
teen you're trying to figure yourself
out and he was trying to figure himself
out too and yeah he's one of my best
friends he's a great guy um but yeah
so so that that I remember I remember
those moments and then
I just became the funny guy really it
was when I moved to LA I became the the
kid that would you know just kind of
like every now and then I get in trouble
with the teachers but I I was like I'm
not a bad kid I'm just a cutup so I'm
not doing drugs I'm not doing anything
like that but
yeah then after After High School you
did what after high school I went to I
went to New York uh to go to NYU uh I
thought I wanted to be uh an actor I
always wanted to be a comedian but I was
like I'll do an I'll be an actor and
I'll I'll get into it that way which is
so stupid to think about now but um so I
went to NYU and I was in acting school
which was like not for me just acting
school is
like it was like we had the classes were
voice uh uh there was voice class and
speech class and then there was movement
and I was just like there was no class
that was acting and I'm they wanted to
make it so uh they wanted break it down
so much to where you know it was like
they want to break down all the parts of
acting and then you could assemble it
later on like by the fourth year and it
was like Voltron it was like you use all
these pieces together and now you're an
actor and it's like get the [__] out of
here dude I the first I I dropped out H
and I and and I was like I don't want if
this is what it is I don't even want to
do it I don't even want to be an actor
so I started writing uh I wrote some
scripts I got they were optioned I got
paid never got made and then at a at a
loss like as my final like I was like I
don't know what to do I was 25 I was
like I'm just going to get on I've
always been putting this off I want to
do stand up I want to do stand up um and
then when I start when I did stand up I
did my first show it was like oh [__] I
can have an immediate reaction from
people and I don't have to wait nine
months to hear for like either about
acting job or a writing job and this is
great and so I just did stand up every
single night since then pretty much um
but yeah so uh after after high school I
I did one year of college and then
that's when I did
um then I would I like for a few years I
was kind of trying trying to figure out
what to do and then that's when I
started standing up at 25 and then after
that I knew what my life
was and you enjoy
it you got to
I
love standup more than anything I
Thought I Loved stand up more than
anything until I became a father um and
that's what I love the most but uh and I
I was convinced I was like there is no
[__] way that I will like anything
more than stand up I was like I was like
go I was like We'll see people say being
a dad is the best people say like having
a family is the best we'll see I I'm
still G to do I remember think I
remember watching a um uh an interview
with Dennis Miller when I was a kid and
I wanted to do standup and I I was
watching Dennis Miller on TV and Dennis
Miller they said what do you like more
being a a comedian or being um
uh a father and he said oh I love doing
standup but if it was between that and
my kids I wouldn't tell another joke for
the rest of my life and I remember as a
kid thinking what a [__] [__] I
remember as like I must have been 156
I'm like that what a [__] and now I get
it I get it it's
so and I to truly get it and to not just
like to like understand it is wild it's
really wild I almost feel like a
betrayal like to myself no you can still
do both I know you can still do both but
I was so hard lined as
a black and white as a as a as a as a
16-year-old like I I was just so black
and white like I got my
heartbroken and then my best friend
started dating uh the girl and I REM and
that was that was the same month I
discovered Tupac's music so I was like
this world is [__] I'm coming you know
um I know about Tupac and I got my heart
broken yeah I'm from linat but still
like I was like I'm still a little bit
you know I I was like I am who I am in
my head not who these [__]
think I am and I was
like I just remember thinking like it's
black and white and then so when I
became a comedian I was like this is it
I make people laugh I I hated
like I I anytime a conversation got too
serious I I would be like all right we
got to make fun of we got to make fun of
one of us this is just uncomfortable for
me you know and um so I thought that was
the world I live in like the comedic
world it's all you know that was what I
do and um once I started having kids in
a family that you can do both which is
the gray area but
um yeah I I I if I if I if I talk to the
16-year-old me I I would I I know I I
know
I know I'm being a [__] but it's for
the better you
know um but yeah the you
know I have a four-year-old and a and a
9-month-old now and uh nine-month-old is
just kind of rolling around but the uh
the
four-year-old's I mean it's it's it's
funny to see him understand the currency
that uh humor has in our family just
immediately he gets it
um and
uh yeah
it's I I want him to know that
like I think when when I was a kid I
used humor which I didn't realize this
until the past few years it's like I
used it as a defense mechanism I mean
you'd always hear oh you use humor
people use humor as defense mechanism
but I that [__] seemed so tired and like
I'm like okay I know that but also I
just like to be funny but a lot of it is
just true I would just do it cuz I
didn't want to live in that year or
whatever I was living um whether it be
from you know moving to LA and not
knowing every fish out of water or
bullies or or just you know I not being
able to sleep at night and um so I want
I I was always like I felt like I was
like now I understand I was using humor
to cope with that [__] um but I want my
sons now to know
that you can do that but it's also okay
to to you're okay as you are it's also
okay to be to have these feelings and be
scared cuz I I don't I don't for some
reason that missed me when I was when I
was younger and I don't think it's my
parents fault like it's not like they
didn't try to teach me about that but I
just maybe I was too wrapped up in my
own head maybe it's just the composition
of my [__] brain but like it just
like it NE it it didn't sink in I I
never felt okay I never felt okay I
never felt okay and um when I was making
people laugh I felt okay right yeah yeah
it makes perfect sense
yeah who who did you look up to as a
comedian when you were starting as a
comedian I looked up to
uh Eddie Murphy when when I saw his
first he was incredible yeah I just I
was like I mean he was like 22 when he
was doing that [__] and I was just like
oh this is I look he's great and I'm not
but I I I I knew I could do like a I'm
like I could do a version of that like
if if that he's just standing I do that
with my friends and like there's
something in there I can do I'm not you
know he's one of the greatest I'm not
saying like I can do what he's doing but
like I was like I can I can do that in
front of people I know I know he he
because that's one of the things of
being a comedian is like one of the
things about being a comedian is you you
make it look easy that's part of the job
so that's why everybody thinks like I
can do that [__] you know um so I I was
hit with that a little bit and then and
then once I saw like Jim Carrey and I
realized you can be like so ridiculous
and overboard I was like oh man that the
balls of this [__] I was like I
can I want to do that like Jim Carrey
was insane and Eddie Murphy was such a
good performer um that I was those two
were the guys so many such different
styles yeah different styles but I was
like oh those those two are my those two
are my guys yeah yeah they were great
yeah know
and then as I as I as I got older I
uh in my 20s I I started like watching
like the the guys who were coming up I
didn't like seeing like the famous guys
cuz I wanted to see what like
the the guys I didn't know were what
what they were talking about because um
I always found it interesting like
someone who doesn't have some sort of
fan base or following like to to be like
hey you guys paid me to make you laugh
and you don't even know who the [__] I
am is insane like you're just a comedian
like that's an uphill battle just from
jump to me that's the most impressive
thing is to just be like to just show up
to work with nothing like you know I I
guess people say the most po most
popular thing to guys want to be is like
a rock star it's like that sounds
terrible to me like you got to have all
the equipment and [__] and some of you
got to paint your faces and you got to
scream into a microphone it's exhausting
dude I just want to like show up you
know there's been nights where the mic
went out and I just put it down and I
just started you know back to my project
days and when I was doing plays and [__]
I would just be like I don't need a
microphone and I was just that that that
that's cool to
me
yeah yeah no band no equipment no
nothing no no nothing just show up
that's so cool to me like it's [__]
1420 or some [__] like it's like you
know what I mean like you don't need
anything stand on a box and do it you
stand on a [__] box you know I love
that [__] like there's guys that used to
do uh standup in like New York and like
Washington Square Park just like
standing on a
box those are the best comedians that
have ever lived I mean if you can do
that
[__] you're a You're a murderer You're a
murderer on on on stage if you can do
that you can do any because that's the
thing it's like most people always say
like what is it like to bomb and it's
like you're only bombing if you
think you're bombing or if you feel a
certain way about it you're not bombing
if you're
just on stage and no one's laughing and
you don't give a [__] like who cares
you're bombing if you're on stage people
don't laugh and it gets to you cuz
then that feeling sucks but it doesn't
suck if you're not you're like all you
guys don't think this is funny but I'm
[__] what what are the elements that
make it that make comedy great I mean of
course there's the timing and the the
attitude and the yeah it's it's the
jokes of course it's it's it's I I think
it's just like what it it's
what's you have to be confident you have
to be confident and it's the it's the
way you say it and even if you're not
look comedians are the most insecure
[__] in the world that's what's
ironic right yeah confidence is like the
key to it but then it's the key to it
confidence is the key to
it I remember
like doing
uh a gig
and I went on after the guy
who um brought everybody to the show and
I he was he was killing I didn't know
that he knew everybody in the
audience
and I'm like this
guy's
terrible and they're they're dying like
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna wait like
it was like a way till they get hello to
me
thing and he got off stage and I was
like all right here we go and I went on
stage and I I mean I
ate plates of [__] it was like I I was
like I didn't understand I I remember on
stage thinking like oh I had already
bombed but I remember thinking oh this
is bombing like like and I sat down for
the first time ever on on I never sat
down cuz I was always up and you know I
sat down and I remember saying to the
audience guys I swear I swear I'm funny
and then they laughed and
I
uh I remember getting mad at them
laughing for that cuz I'm like of course
they [__] laughed at that because
that was a real moment and it's so
annoying how people laugh at the [__]
truth not my jokes and
uh because they felt how bad I felt in
that moment and it was kind of a relief
to them and in a way it was me showing
them the reality of the
situation which then after that I was
like okay that's what I'm scared of the
most is just [__] eating plates of
[__] in front of a bunch of
strangers but I'm still doing what I do
every day after that nothing really
changed except the feeling inside me so
[__] it I'm going to go eat plates of
[__] in front of man I ate plates of
[__] I I mean I go and do
rooms that had no business doing you you
know this is something that's common for
standup you go you play laundromats you
play uh uh coffee shops where you play
[__] uh bars where you're on stage
and there's um PE and there's a football
game on and people are like this and
you're over there and you're like I know
the Dolphins are playing
but aren't cargo pants weird you know
and like people are like shut shut the
[__] up and even you're like I should
shut the [__] up they shouldn't have a
show here you know and but that's how
you get good and and go ahead ignore me
as much as you
want I'll I'll get better and
um you know that's why I I I think about
this like Tik Tok generation of uh
Comics that not even Tik Tok but like
internet yeah people that are like hey I
I have a a [__] reality show of
selling houses and that's over I guess
I'll do standup and you're like and then
they and then like they're terrible
because like you don't eat plates of
[__] you got to eat plates of
[__] you can't just be famous for some
stand the only thing is like I'm famous
for this one thing ah now now I'm Drew
Carrey it's like what are you talking
about Drew Carrey A of [__] before he
did the [__] you know um but and and
that's not to say that there's guys that
cultivate a following
online
uh that you know on Tik Tok or whatever
it is that are true comedians that are
good that have cut their teeth in the
clubs but there are those people that
are
like you know hey time to do standup
it's funny to think of like that like
standup is like it's it's it's just look
I get that there's like brain surgery
and I understand that there's people
trying to figure out time travel but
like standup is just in that world
that's one of the hardest things to do
that somebody that's just like sees
another comic doing doing well on stage
that is just like some guy successful in
another field that's like I could I I
could do that [__] it's just so funny
because it's so not the
case there's no way to become great at
any field yeah without putting in that
kind of yeah those difficult times
what's where you ever bombed the worst I
ever
bombed wow uh the worst I ever
bombed I would probably say it would be
that moment that I told because because
pretty bad you're competing against a
football game or TV said but the reason
why I think that one was so bad is
because that was the first time and I
remembered I still remember the feeling
of it and I I remember thinking like
it's never going to be that bad again
cuz now I know what it is you know it's
like it's like you're afraid of what you
don't know you know it's like that's
what [__] that's why people are
racist you know it's like I'm white I
only know whites I don't know these
other guys so I I don't I don't know if
I like them and it's like no you're just
being racist like I can't like I
don't I now I know what bombing
is it's like that's what I'm afraid of
and [__] it I could be I could be
friends with them you know like it's uh
but that was the that was probably the
worst time I mean there's been plenty of
times there's been plenty of times I
remember one time this is a this is a
really this is a this is a good story
about uh Redemption I remember one time
I got a gig in Las Vegas um this guy I
don't remember how I got the gig but
this guy reached out to I guess it was
my agent and my manager and he was like
hey we want Chris Leia to to do uh an
hour of standup for our uh
um corporate gig cor corporate gigs are
the worst you might as well host the
[__] Golden Gloves it's just the
worst gig right because there's tables
everyone thinks they're the funniest guy
in a room uh it's in like a place that
would be
like a baseball card Convention Center
you know what I mean like it's like it's
just it's awful the lighting's
bad and I'm like sure I'll do it they
also pay the most so I'm like yeah I
don't give a [__] like what am I going
to do bomb who gives a [__] so my my ma
my agent was like uh my manager was like
look you you know it's a tough gig
everyone who's done it says it's really
tough uh Paul Riser did it two years ago
and he was like it was the worst gig you
ever did so I don't know if you want to
do it and I was like [__] Paul Riser
like I haven't
even heard that name in so long I'll be
fine you know like I I do clubs every
night I'm working my muscle it's fine so
I get
there and the guy is this older man and
he was like Chris and I was like yeah he
said we're really excited to have you
here uh
um uh my my son is a is a huge fan I
gotta be honest I don't know who you are
but he was like you got to get this guy
um I remember his son was my age and he
was like uh so so I I got some advice
for you and I'm like all right here we
go like the [__] guy's going to tell
me what to do so he's
like it's a really hard gig he's like we
had Paul he's like we had Paul Riser
here and he he really bombed and I
shouldn't be saying this [__] about Paul
RIS whatever we all bomb is great he's
great and by the
way everyone bombs but so he was like
um the guys who've done well are guys
who just come up and roast us so you
should roast us and I'm like I remember
thinking in my head this [__]
doesn't understand what I'm going to do
I'm going to go out there I'm going to
do my jokes it's going to be great I'm a
professional comedian I just did it last
night I killed it's going to be fine so
I say okay no problem I was like he does
even know who I am his son knows who I
am it's like I got this [__]
so I go I go
out and I do I have my hour and I'm
about to by the way tape my special like
it's all locked in I do the first joke
not good fine you know sometimes it
takes a few I do another joke not good I
do my I get into like my fifth minute
and it's going worse than when it
started so I'm like this is so
interesting I'm going to get this crowd
dude I'm telling you I looked at my
watch it was a half an hour of a [__]
Ted Talk it might as well have just been
like this like it was like the worst and
I remember going back to that first bomb
thinking like dude this is one of those
[__] times like where they all know
each other and
like so I remember saying hey what's up
with you and I was and so I started
talking like the guy said and the guy's
like I do this I start making I start
saying it making fun of the guy he's
telling me he owns a Lamborghini so I
makeing fun of them it's easy to make
fun of them cuz all the guys are like
this [__] own like Lamborghini
like they already don't like this guy
secretly so I'm like exposing this and
I'm like making fun bro they start
laughing and then they start dying and I
don't stop making fun of them cuz I'm
like and in my head the last La second
hour the second half hour I'm
like you're never as a comic smarter
than the [__] room you're never
smarter than the room you're never
smarter than the room like you think
like you know when you're [__] you're
like you got to go talk to your friend
or something and you're you're you're
driving along and you're like I'm going
to talk to my friend I really got to
talk to about this thing I'm going to
say this thing and then I'm going to get
to the point where I say that thing and
they're going to say that thing and then
I'm going to get I'm going to wrap it up
like that and then you go and
like I remember when I was on a a a
flight to uh Canada I was an Air Canada
and they speak [__] French and [__]
in the flight and um and I feel like
they do that to [__] with you like they
know I'm not French and they come in
they're like BL blah BL blah and I'm
like I don't I don't and then they go ah
and then they have to so they you're
already one down you know and so uh on
Air Canada they don't have [__]
Wi-Fi and I didn't know this [__] and
we're like flying up to the sky and you
know you're always like Wai and you're
like am I 10,000 ft in the air yet cuz
cuz I want like they like for some like
like the Wi-Fi is up in the clouds like
it's [__] everywhere you know but
like you got to wait because they make
up some [__] about like traffic
control whatever and so I'm like looking
out the window I'm like dude I think
this is over 10,000 ft like uh they
better not not have Wi-Fi cuz it's
[__] 2023 right at this point and I'm
like I can't wait to ask this [__]
flight attendant about the Wi-Fi because
when she says that there's no Wi-Fi I'm
gonna [__] I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make them feel stupid for not having
Wi-Fi like this is how the conversation
is GNA go so she comes up she
starts I was like I'm gonna say uh
whatever I was like dude I'm such a
[__] idiot I was like I'm going to
get to the point where I could say like
where where I can say like
uh where's the I was going to say
where's the Wi-Fi and in my head she was
going to say oh it was going to put her
back on her feet so then I could say
it's 2023 and that will be the end of
the conversation like you
know so I said she came by and I was
like I was ready I was hot cuz I was
like I can't believe there's not going
to be Wi-Fi and I said uh there's no I
said hey uh where's the Wi-Fi and she
said you don't
know and I said
what and I said what and she said we
don't have them on these flights and I
was like but and in my head I'm like how
the [__] am I going to get to the part
where I L say like but it's 2023 and
make her back on her feet and the whole
conversation just went to [__] and I was
the [__] [__] here cuz we don't have
them on these planes and it's just like
that's how life goes like that's
how you think you're going to go in
you're going to say this and that's
going to happen and then this is going
to happen and then you got it all
planned out and then you go and you say
the thing you were going to say and then
the flight says you don't know and
you're like I I don't know
what you
lose just got to be ready for anything
so that was one of the hardest I ever
bought but then the second half of that
CRA I got him good you warmed him up I
got them and they ended up G standing
standing evation at the end so it's a
it's a tale of redemption
but yeah I had to figure out that room
you're never smarter than the room
whether you're in that room or on an
airplane you're just you're never
smarter than the room but what's what's
been the roughest thing you've had to
deal with in your life in my life the
roughest thing I've had to deal with was
uh being
cancelled uh
and my life blowing up
um 100% it was the hardest thing I've
had to deal with um I would say yeah
it's got to be terrible you're being in
the public eye yeah and being being
singled out like that it's
the yeah it's it's horrible it's um it's
horrible it's horrible
it's
it's funny because there's never a u
this was a time when a lot of guys were
being picked on right taken down yeah
taken down there's not
um it's always weird it's it's always
interesting talking about it because
there's no I still feel like there's no
real right way to talk about it without
people
just you know being angry at all sides
both sides have stand on it well the
truth is
people lie
and uh
and and it's you know whatever the media
makes something out to be is not the
truth it's just not no matter what way
it's going it's just um and when you're
someone that is in the media good or bad
you you see that but I think the com the
common person doesn't um and it's it's
it's it's really wild it's really wild
um that's the hardest thing that I've
I've dealt with and
um it's
also look when something [__] up
happens you can
uh you can make anything the best thing
that ever happened to you really as long
as
you learn and figure
out how how to do that and it's all up
to you very often the worst thing that
happens to someone is the best thing
that ever
yeah and you
know look at I
mean I know who I am and the people who
are very close to me know who I am and
um you look at
this world and how divisive it is and
how black and
white it is
and as an adult you know
it's you know it's
not you know it's not black and white
you know you know it's Shades of Gray
but then you go online and it's black
and
white and it's very
easy to
let the
darkness swallow you um
when
you're when you see that [__] um because
you're thinking your career's over
you're thinking a lot of things are over
you're
thinking you're not even thinking you're
feeling
you're it's never as bad as you think it
is when it happens whatever that thing
is you know my son falls down hits his
knee he's crying and I know it's okay
and he doesn't cuz he's never hit his
his knee
before
um and uh I always tell him like buddy
it's all right the worst part's over you
know and
uh you
think if I'm honest um you think
okay something that I would go always go
back to no matter how hard it was um
during that time I would I would say
like like everything's okay because no
matter what I can I
can end my life
and and
not feel this
right and I would constantly think of
that
like all good everything's fine you can
always end your life you got that bad
for
you
yeah
um m mhm was there some truth in the
allegations I was a womanizer um and
that's the truth
um
and no I mean what I was canceled for
was is was not the truth uh um but it
doesn't matter that's just perception is
kind of a lot of people um I was out
there H having sex uh
all the time uh with with people I
barely knew you know and that's I
realize
how that can get you don't know
people's you don't know people so you
how how do you know if you don't know
them you don't know what they what
they're what they're like and what you
know it's I was definitely like and I
had a chip on my shoulder too I was like
well they don't nobody likes me they
just think they they they they like me
now they wouldn't have liked me when I
was being [__] bullied in high school
they just like me now because I'm
[__] I'm on tour I'm I'm famous you
know and I remember having a chip on my
shoulder about that and thinking
uh it was just a weird wrong [__]
stupid way to live like I was all
consumed in all of it you know I would
go I
would make people laugh and I would try
to get laid celebrity is a intoxicating
drug isn't it what's that a celebrity is
an intoxicating yeah man I especially
for a young man I
wish I wish I [__] I
wish it's a weird thing because it's
like everyone thinks
it's the goal is to be
famous um
and it's not bad it's just there are
good and bad things to everything and
uh
I it's just
hard you can't surround yourself with
people that are just
like you're
great
cuz then you'll become an insane person
because you're not great all the
time I remember thinking like I remember
too my my dad when I was
uh when I was younger and come coming up
in before I even
really was any name or had any kind of
people come see me
my dad would
say
um you have to be careful because people
are going to start to like you and
they're not going to know you and it's
very easy to get a chip on your shoulder
and
um don't let that consume you and and
and I knew everything when I was younger
so
I didn't really listen you
know and uh it's kind of
just what happened I just I yeah what
are the worst sides worst aspects of or
what are the worst things about going
through something like that being
canceled your family's got to yeah the
worst thing about one of one of the
worst things about going about um going
through something like that is
uh
people think
that they think that
you're you're who you are online you
know and that
your Instagram is reality and you show
the good moments on Instagram not I mean
I I was off the internet for a year or
so um and it wasn't good it was only bad
and the one of the worst Parts though
about it is that they think is that
people I don't think I don't think that
they realize how much that stuff doesn't
just
affect it doesn't affect only you it it
it it
um it it affects
your uh it affects your dad it affects
your mom it affects your
uh your family and your loved ones and
uh you it's very hard
to figure out how to put
your house on fire
out uh when people are
mad
at the thing that's not the problem you
know
um you know I I I
uh people are you know people would
be angry at a certain thing that I it's
just as as as that isn't true so
how this is why I got so deep in the in
the woods of it I'm
like I don't even
know how to fix the right thing
because people don't know people don't
know what is actually happening so um
that's why I that's why I
um that's why I couldn't
really yeah that's why I wanted to
that's why I didn't want to that's why I
wanted to
um yeah that's why I wanted to end my
life but um
my seeing like my dad and
like my my wife
and I had just brought a child into the
world
um I don't know it was just
um it
was it's weird it's been four years now
and
I
I was just out having a coffee with my
wife and it was a be it's a beautiful
day and
um it was so nice and we were smiling
and
[__] and to to to be in this room now
and talk about that and think
about the feeling and to like force
myself to not make a joke of it
which is
what
I'm I was told to do in
rehab is
uh it's difficult but I guess it's
necessary not I know I don't know I I
it's I just I just want
to I want to
be I want my sons to be proud of me and
[__] and I thought that that was going
to be
through my status and standup and all
that
but uh it's not it's just going to be
through who I am and they're going to
know who I am
and
I don't know man it's just all such a
[__] I hate to say something so
generic or like
[Music]
hashtagyoloswag
oh
God I you know Jesus yeah I [__] hate
going to therapy I go to so much therapy
and
like the twists and turns and the ups
and downs life I just [__] hate it
bro why people say like oh don't you
just love going to therapy it's like dud
what are you talking about there what
are you talking about there you
know you're still a young man you got
plenty of years ahead of you I just get
Dumber bro I
what's been your favorite point of your
career my favorite point of my career is
uh it was probably when I did my last
special um and you're getting better as
it as years go on I I feel that way your
delivery your T oh thank you oh I I
didn't know if you were I thought you
were asking me that uh yeah no I I do
feel that way thanks for saying that um
I feel like I'm getting better uh I I I
feel like you have to use your
experiences at some point look I you
know I I I I was and am a silly
[__] and when I did stand up the
first half of my career I was like I
just want to make people laugh I don't
give a [__] about this oh the truth is
what's funny and now you know you you
you got to get to a point where I've
done four five specials it's like okay
what else is there I'm not just going to
talk about some silly [__] type of
person that type of people blanketly and
um so I I used my experiences and I
started talking about it and um I found
the humor in it and I I knew it was
going to be the hardest thing I ever did
artistically and uh it was and I'm
really proud of it so the last one that
my last special that came out grow or
die was probably the the thing that I'm
I'm most proud of yeah you you write
your own material yeah I write my own
material yeah um I just kind of think
about it and then go talk about it on
stage yeah what what helps you create
what helps you come up with really great
stuff uh
pressure pressure probably going through
tough times too going through tough
times yeah I mean a lot of it is about
being funny but then a lot of it is
cutting the tension you know like but
mean what you went through four years
ago has probably made you a better man a
better comedian yeah it it has it has um
it has it because because it has to
without those experiences without the
mistakes and and growing from it well
that's why I call my special grower die
you know you can
either or die it's there's
nothing there's no in between really um
so it's funny how so many people I've
interviewed who have been through
horrific things kind of like you maybe
what you went through you ask them like
do you wish you had never gone through
that and they all say no I wish I had I
would go through it again yeah it's
interesting
I I've thought about that before
like because you know I I
I always think about
like imagine who you'd be if he hadn't
yeah and and I don't know you probably
wouldn't be married I don't know what I
do know
is you
I I was a
lot and even thinking about like my my
wife
like being so opinionated and and nah
we're not going to do this we're going
to do this you know like nah I don't
want to do that [__] that's Corny let's
[__] do that like I was just such
a a guy in a room that was like oh he's
here you know like and I'm just not that
anymore uh and I can still be that way
comedically I have my podcast that I
talk [__] is just me but
like I'm just a more full person dude I
I it had to be that way man like I I I
just getting told like yes all the time
can is just you you be you become a
crazy motherucker [__] like I
just I don't yeah it's just I I I I'm
very I'm navigating it and I'm very
happy with how I'm navigating it and
it's you know look when the [__] hits
the fan you don't [__] change
immediately it's
a process it's a process you know uh
celebrity is a hell of a thing to go
through yeah it's I don't such such as
unusual crazy thing for any human to go
through through but then you see people
like like the the superstars like uh
Elvis Presley and Michael Jackson they
they go off the rails I would if I was
that
famous if I was that famous if I was the
I don't know how the rock does it I
don't know how these [__] do it
I I
I cuz the other thing
is you're just a you're you're you're
portraying some someone you're not you
you can't be that big and be you like
who'd the [__] rock vote for we don't
know like we if he says it then the idea
of some people's version of the rock is
shattered bro people going to cry if if
the rock said hey if the rock said hey I
voted for this person at least a
thousand people would cry in the world
that's crazy you you you don't want to
be that powerful that's insane if I say
I voted for [__] Trump I voted for V
Biden and and at least a thousand people
cry because you shatter your Dre I don't
want to shatter people's dreams so
that's why it's like you want to you
want to I I could never be that you know
you see these guys on like the [__]
couch of Kimmel and they're just like
everyone I worked with was amazing it's
like no they weren't no they weren't
you're [__]
lying and I know that and we all
secretly know that so what are we doing
and I can't I can't be that I can't be
that kind of person and I I have I
also
want to come from a place of understand
of understanding like I understand why
people uh need to be that way like we
can forgive Elijah Wood for being on the
[__] couch and Co be for being like I
I just worked with the most amazing
people it's like dude that's who we has
to be he can't be a guy that's like yeah
[__] this [__] you know that's what
comedians are for I guess it's like
you're you're you're you're representing
a person and I I just could never I
could never do that I could never do
that because
the Elvis the the the the the Michael
Jackson the rock or
whatever oh my god
dude that's a yeah that's a recipe for
disaster I feel like and it and it was
right they didn't they didn't end well
it's not like they were
[__] rock do okay even the movies
about them you're like oh God movies are
supposed to be good and you're like oh
this is tough you
know yeah there's no class you can take
to figure out how to navigate it no and
uh
it's it's
uh [__] I don't know I don't think
people are supposed to
be that famous famous yeah you know I
don't think people are supposed to be
that
famous
like I already think that when I walk
into a room everybody is going to be
like ah [__] this guy this guy did that
joke about that he's just [__] stupid
comedy and like to
be like the
rock yeah you can't even go places but
everyone loves the rock so [__] if I
guess I don't know everyone loves the
rock right so I'm doing it
wrong I need to start working out
harder
comedians have have a very different
life than than actors and things like
that well I think comedians people are
often like you know my my my humor I I
think is very like like I'll be on my
podcast I'll be talking about you'll
hear
like a lot of comedians yourself Bill
bur uh Chappelle will say things that
like no one can say true yeah they'll
say things that just no like you're
going to get yeah crucified if you say
it they say it and and you do but you
realize how much it doesn't matter
really CU you know I'll I said something
you got a license to say things that no
one else can say I said something
recently about the the the uh um
Southwest
Airlines how fat if you're fat you get a
free
seat if you're too fat and it's like I I
was on stage and I was like I was just
talking about it and I was like they
[__] fat people won they figured it
out they get to eat whatever the [__]
they want they can be as fat as they
want and end up getting free [__]
because of it like um and I was on stage
which means I was trying to make people
laugh I put it online and people were
just
like you know of of course most people
thought it was funny but most but there
were a lot of people that are like wow
are you serious this and that you know
yeah that's social media it's social
media and then you go and then you're
like oh you might see 15 people on
social media hate you and you think oh
this is the worst day of my life but
then you go out on the street and
everyone's like hey it's not real
life um
so yeah but you you still got to keep
saying it and and and and
and that they they are trying to take
every comedian down from in one way or
another whether it's with what you say
or accusations or what but yeah it's uh
I think you I think the goal is just
ignore it yeah it is the goal is ignore
it yeah the goal is ignore it because I
think smart enough people can sniff out
I think smart enough people can sniff
out who you really are I think you know
and and and what's real and and
um I mean I'm not up here right now
bullshitting and people are going to
still think I'm bullshitting and people
are going to think I'm not bullshitting
um
so like I said the only thing that
matters and it's hard to keep this in my
mind but the only thing that matters is
the people who truly know me know me
and the people I love and the people
that love me are the people that matter
to me um and everyone else if they like
me that's
nice that's that's nice too but that's
nice too
and
I guess it's I guess it's not what
matters it feels weird saying that even
still I so badly want people to like me
still is is that is that the is that the
goal for said a lot of comedians I said
it in my last special I always thought
that I was doing standup to
to make people laugh I was talking to my
therapist and she was like well yeah but
you you want to be accepted is really
the thing and I was like that [__] me
up and I guess I might have known that
but hearing it in that moment
after 2020 going through all my [__]
like hearing my therapist say like it's
acceptance is what you need and I I was
like that [__] me up CU I was like man
I always thought I want to make people
laugh I I I always thought I did stand
up to make people laugh but it turns out
I do it to make sure that I don't cry
which is like a mind-blowing [__]
thing to me you might lose your Edge if
you if you figured it all out I know I
know and became healthy I know I know
but so it's like I
uh I
just I like to make people laugh but I
also know I have to know what it is I
have to
know that it's it's it's for me too it's
for me as well not not just not you know
I'm
not it's self- serving you know and uh I
can't get caught up in that I can't get
caught up in the uh
I can't get cut off in in in in either
aspect of it in in me either trying to
make you laugh or
me trying to make myself feel better
it's all part of it it's all gray it's
not black and white and uh and that's
okay
and yeah it's um I do still want people
to like
me but but as an artist but I know what
that is as an artist as a comedian I
think your your job is to to to not
please your audience it's it's to show
your audience what's funny right right
to to you you know better than they do
right which is why they're paying to see
you why they're paying to see you and
and and
you you don't listen to any you listen
to yourself yeah the more you can listen
to yourself the better you do and that
gets harder the more people saying yes
around you you know cuz like that that
that's the thing you're an environment
that's going to right that's why people
so many people lose their Edge yeah um
but uh yeah it it it sucks when you know
my wife is like that's [__] stupid
but it's necessary you know it's
interesting how many careers of of
musicians artists actors
everything have peaked like just white
hot when they were whatever maybe in
their 20s yeah yeah and it was just they
could do no wrong there's nobody like
them yeah and then as
they continued their success and
everybody was kissing their ass and they
were the greatest ever walk the earth
they kind of lost that edge they were
still great because they had that
history of doing great stuff but they as
if they were producing the work they
were after they become became big they
wouldn't have become big I know it's cuz
you start thinking too much man it's
because you start [__] realizing how
much you don't [__] know which is the
worst and the best I guess I mean I
think the key is just to stay humble and
never listen to anybody I know yeah got
to stay [__] humble which sucks be
cool to not be humble be cool to just be
like well supremely confident but also
humble at the same time yeah it's a mix
it's a mix they're almost like opposites
yeah Chris what what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life the most important lesson I've
learned in my
life um
probably it's probably um
that that um
I'm I'm okay as I am you
know took a long time to realize that
but probably
that it's probably that I'm okay as I am
yeah you
are thanks man all right Chris Leah
thank you so much thank you super
interesting thanks thanks man